SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
THEY'RE AWESOME GALGIANI.
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HELLO.
HUESO --
TADO.
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES WELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
GEN TINA [inaudible]
ROCK [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
JOAN.
I'M BURKE.
WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WELL.
COLLEAGUES A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
IN THE GALLERY.
AND BEYOND THE RAIL PLEASE RISE
WE WILL BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING AND WE
WILL B. LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
BY SENATOR PAM.
LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE.
THE BUDDHIST MONK TECH NOT HAN
SAYS.
WAKING UP EACH DAY I SMILE.
TWENTY FOUR BRAND NEW HOURS ARE
BEFORE ME.
I VOWED TO LIVE IN EACH MOMENT
AND TO LOOK AT ALL BEINGS WITH
THE EYES OF COMPASSION
[inaudible]
HOLY MYSTERY.
AS WE BEGIN ANOTHER NEW YEAR
CHINESE NEW YEAR.
HELP US TO NOTICE THE BLESSINGS
OF EACH DAY.
THE OPPORTUNITIES TO APPRECIATE
EACH MOMENT.
AND THE GIFT OF COMPASSION BUT
WE CAN GIVE TO ONE ANOTHER.
AMEN.
ELECTIONS --
OF THE UNITED STATES OR REPUBLIC
FOR WHICH IT STANDS --
THERE'S COOL.
YEAH. FOR OUR SHE'S TWO
PRIVILEGES.
OF THE FLOOR IF WE COULD DRAW.
YOUR SILENCE AND ATTENTION TO
SENATOR PAM SENATOR PAN THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU --
MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS.
SHOOTING QUITE A LOT.
HAPPY NEW YEAR --
AS A REPRESENT THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS HAVE
A LIKE TO WISH EVERYONE A HAPPY
LUNAR NEW YEAR I KNOW WE ARE ALL
HERE DRESSED IN RED TO REMEMBER.
ABOUT WOMEN'S HEART HEALTH BUT
ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT RED IS THE
COLOR OF GOOD LOCK.
AND SO I THINK IT'S ALSO
APPROPRIATE THAT --
WE CELEBRATE --
TO THIS COMING YEAR WITH THE
GOOD FORTUNE AND PROSPERITY.
BECAUSE TOMORROW IS LUNAR NEW
YEAR.
AND IT'S THE YEAR OF THE PIG --
THE YEAR THE PIG MARKS THE LAST
YEAR THE TWELVE YEARS OF THE X.
CYCLE.
BUT IS THE FIRST YEAR THAT THE
LEARN NEW LUNAR NEW YEAR IS
OFFICIALLY RECOGNIZED AS A DAY
OF SPECIAL SIGNIFICANCE BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AS RESULT OF SB EIGHT NINETY TWO
AND I WANT TO THANK MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
OFFERED THAT EFFORTS AND AND
WHICH IN WHICH I JOIN WITH HIM
TO PASS AND WHICH WE SIGNED LAST
YEAR.
AND CERTAINLY TOO MANY M. ASIAN
AMERICANS IN OUR STATE LUNAR NEW
YEAR IS ONE THE MOST IMPORTANT
HOLIDAYS OF THE YEAR.
AS MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING MY OWN FAMILY SPEND
QUALITY TIME TOGETHER TO
CELEBRATE I LIKE TO SHARE WITH
YOU SOME OF THE TRADITIONS
ASSOCIATED.
WITH THE LUNAR NEW YEAR.
ON YOUR DESK YOU'LL FIND A
MANDARIN.
MANDARINS AND ORANGES ARE
EXTREMELY SYMBOLIC IN ASIAN
CULTURES.
THE ROUND SHAPE OF THE MANDARIN
SIGNIFIES FAMILY UNITY.
AND ITS GOLDEN COLOR REPRESENTS
WEALTH.
MANDARIN'S ARE GIVEN AS A
GESTURE OF GOOD WILL.
CHILDREN AND UNMARRIED ADULTS
ARE ALSO GIVEN RED ENVELOPES.
CONTAINING MONEY FOR GOOD LUCK.
RED IS THE COLOR CELEBRATION IN
MANY ASIAN CULTURES.
NOW I'D SAY AND FORTUNATELY THE
ENVELOPES YOU'RE RECEIVING DO
NOT CONTAIN MONEY BUT THEY DO
CONTAIN.
FESTIVE HOLIDAY CANDY WHICH ARE
PRINTED WITH CHARACTERS FOR
FORTUNE AND WEALTH.
SO AS WE JOIN TOGETHER TO RING
IN THE YEAR THE PIG I ENCOURAGE
ALL OF YOU TO JOIN LOCAL
FESTIVITIES IN YOUR DISTRICTS.
THE NEW YEAR CELEBRATIONS IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
ILLUSTRATE ARE CALLED STATES
RICH CULTURE HISTORY AND
ADVERSITY.
OUR CAUCUS IS KICKING OFF THE
FESTIVITIES THIS EVENING AND
INVITES ALL OF YOU TO JOIN US
FOR LUNAR NEW YEAR RECEPTION AT
FIVE O'CLOCK AND ROOM.
THREE SEVENTEEN SO AGAIN I WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL AND PLEASE JOIN
THE API LETS THEY'VE CAUCUS AND
WISHING EVERY CALIFORNIAN.
HEALTHY AND PROSPEROUS NEW YEAR
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN AND HAPPY
NEW YEAR INDEED [inaudible]
SENATOR CAFIERO.
UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR AT
THE PRO TEM'S DESK PLEASE.
SENATOR CAFIERO FLOOR IS YOURS
MADAM PRESIDENT AND SENATORS I'M
HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY WITH
DOCTOR GLENDALE HUMUS THAT.
CURRENT VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE AND NATURAL
RESOURCES.
TODAY GIVES ME GREAT PLEASURE TO
PRESENT HER WITH A RESOLUTION
RECOGNIZING HER AS A RECIPIENT
OF THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA STORED LEADER AWARD.
AN AWARD THAT YOU WON DURING
LIVE FOR AN ECONOMIC SUMMIT.
THIS AWARD RECOGNIZES
INDIVIDUALS FOR THEIR PERSISTENT
AND INNOVATIVE EFFORTS TO BUILD
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND
ENCOURAGE SUSTAINABLE PRACTICES
IN COMMUNITIES ALL OVER THE
STATE.
DOCTOR HE MISSED IT.
HUMANS TEND IS AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO'S LIFELONG PURSUIT OUR
EXEMPLIFIED IN THIS AWARD.
SHE CURRENTLY LEAD THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE NATURAL RESOURCES
WHICH SERVES ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES WITH ITS MISSION TO
CONDUCT RESEARCH AND EXTEND
KNOWLEDGE THAT SOME SUPPORT FOOD
SECURITY.
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENTS SCIENCE
LITERACY YOUTH DEVELOPMENT.
AND RURAL ECONOMIC SUCCESS IN A
GLOBAL ECONOMY.
BEFORE HER CURRENT ROLE DR HUMUS
THEN WAS APPOINTED BY PRESIDENT
OBAMA TO SERVE AS A CALIFORNIA
STATE DIRECTOR OF THE UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE.
RURAL DEVELOPMENT AND SERVED AS
DEPUTY UNDERSECRETARY FOR
NATURAL RESOURCES AND THE
ENVIRONMENT AT THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE UNDER
PRESIDENT CLINTON.
IN ADDITION TO SERVING IN MANY
OTHER PUBLIC SERVICE ROLES.
DOCTOR HUMUS THEN ALSO MANAGE
THE SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT
INSTITUTE IN THE TWO THOUSAND
TWO WORLD SUMMIT FOR SUSTAINABLE
DEVELOPMENT IN SOUTH AFRICA.
AND THE TWO THOUSAND SIX WORLD.
WORLD WATER FORUM IN MEXICO CITY
HER LONG CAREER OF PUBLIC
SERVICE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS AN UNDENIABLY
DEDICATED. ONE FOR HER
OUTSTANDING IN IMPACT OF
CONTRIBUTIONS AT THAT HAVE
IMPROVED AGRICULTURAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PRACTICES
NUTRITION EDUCATION AND ECONOMIC
IN YOUTH DEVELOPMENT THROUGHOUT
THE CALIFORNIA NATIONALLY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CONGRATULATING
HER FOR THIS SIGNIFICANT
ACHIEVEMENT.
A WARM CONGRATULATIONS.
IN ORDER WILL RECEIVE
[inaudible]
AND WILLARD [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES OF COULD WE PLEASE
DIRECTOR ATTENTION TO THE BACK
OF THE ROOM WHERE OUR FORMER
COLLEAGUE.
SENATOR BOB HUFF IS JOINING US
TODAY AND LET'S GIVE HIM A VERY
WARM GREETING THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US.
US SENATOR JONES DO YOU HAVE A
PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES YES --
I HAVE AN INTRODUCTION --
THIS MORNING THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BECAUSE IT'S MY HONOR AND A
PRIVILEGE TO INTRODUCE MY GOOD
FRIEND AND MEDICALLY RETIRED
POLICE OFFICER.
FROM MY DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF
EL CAJON JEFF STEIN.
JEFF HAS BEEN MY FRIEND FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS AND WE CHARGE A LOT
OF GOOD MEMORIES TOGETHER.
HE HAS JUST RECENTLY FOUNDED AND
IS THE THE PRESIDENT.
OF A NEW NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
CALLED FUND.
THIS OGANIZATION PROVIDES
FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO POLICE
OFFICERS WHO ARE INJURED IN THE
LINE OF DUTY.
AND TO THEIR FAMILIES COVER NOW
FAN FUND IS THE ONLY LAW
ENFORCEMENT EMERGENCY FUND IN
THE NATION.
AND THEY ALSO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT TO THE FAMILIES OF
OFFICERS WHO COMMIT SUICIDE.
JEFF IS WORKING TO INCREASE THE
AWARENESS OF HIS NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION AND HELP OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
AND THEIR FAMILIES DURING
DIFFICULT TIMES.
IS -- IN
GETTING THOSE GROUP STARTED IN
HIS UP HERE --
THIS WEEK TO INTRODUCE THE
ORGANIZATION TO CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND IS --
WILL SOON BE TAKEN THE
ORGANIZATION A NATIONWIDE.
I'M GRATEFUL FOR JEFF AND HIS
TEAM FOR TAKING CARE OF THOSE
WHO SACRIFICE THE MOST FOR OUR
COMMUNITY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING JEFF
STEIN TO OUR SENATE FLOOR THANK
YOU THANK YOU IN A WARM WELCOME.
MISTER STEIN.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES.
TAKE A MOMENT
.
MIX COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO S. R..
THIRTEEN SENATOR DORADO.
AND SENATOR RUBIO WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM. TO SENATOR
GARAGE CHAU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION THIRTEEN BY
SENATOR DORADO RELATIVE TO WEAR
RED DAY.
SENATOR DORADO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
SENATE RESOLUTION THIRTEEN
DECLARES FEBRUARY AMERICAN HEART
MONTH.
AND RECOGNIZES THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION'S GAUL RED FOR
WOMEN MOMENT IN CALIFORNIA AND I
WANT TO THANK EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF YOU WAS WEARING RED TODAY.
IT'S GREAT GREAT THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
SORRY.
AS PART OF THIS MOMENT WE
OBSERVE CAPITAL GOES RED DAY.
AND IS AGAIN GOOD TO SEE YOU ALL
WEARING RED.
HEART DISEASE IS THE LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG WOMEN IN
THIS COUNTRY.
AND THIS RESOLUTION SEEKS TO
WEAR RAISE AWARENESS OF THE
IMPACTS OF THIS DISEASE.
TRAGICALLY CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASES AND STROKE KILLED ONE
WOMAN EVERY EIGHTY SECONDS AND
THE UNITED STATES IMAGINE THAT
EVERY EIGHTY SECONDS.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT 80% OF
CARDIAC EVENTS CAN BE PREVENTED
CAN BE PREVENTED.
THE GO RED FOR WOMEN MOVEMENT
ENCOURAGES WOMEN TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT OUR FAMILY MEDICAL HISTORY.
TO MEET WITH OUR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS REGARDING RISK FACTORS.
TO UNDERSTAND THE UNIQUE
SYMPTOMS AND WARNING SIGNS
EXPERIENCED BY US.
AND TO EMPOWER US TO TAKE CHARGE
OF OUR HARD HEALTH.
THE AMERICAN HEART MONTH IS AN
IDEAL TIME TO REMIND AMERICANS
TO FOCUS ON OUR HEARTS AND TO
INSPIRE FAMILY FRIENDS AND
COMMUNITIES TO GET INVOLVED.
ON A PERSONAL NOTE HAVING LOST
MY LATE HUSBAND WHEN HE WAS ONLY
FIFTY TWO RELATED TO HEART
DISEASE.
OF THIS IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT TO ME.
THIS AFTERNOON VOLUNTEERS FROM
THE SUTTER HEART AND VASCULAR
INSTITUTE WILL BE PROVIDING FREE
BLOOD PRESSURE AND HEALTH
SCREENINGS IN ROOM ONE TWELVE OF
THE CAPITAL UNTIL TWO PM.
OF MY COLLEAGUES SENATOR RUBIO
WHO IS JOINTLY OUT THREE IN THIS
WAS RESOLUTION WITH ME WILL
INTRODUCE OUR SPECIAL GUESTS AND
VOLUNTEERS.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION THANK YOU IN BEFORE
WE DO THE INTRODUCTION.
OF IT'S NOW TIME FOR DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM AFTER WE
VOTE WE WILL THEN DO
INTRODUCTIONS UNDER PRIVILEGES
TO THE FLOOR SO --
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WISHES.
TO OF SPEAK ON THIS RESOLUTION
ANY DBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THE
RESOLUTION.
SEEING AND HEARING NON MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS [inaudible]
HI BATES [inaudible]
I FELL [inaudible] FIVE GORGEOUS.
I BRADFORD.
AYE CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
HI DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROVE [inaudible]
HI HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HI HILL.
HI WITH A FIVE TADO.
HI JACKSON.
AYE JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible] FIVE
AROUND [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI PAN [inaudible]
HI PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI ROB [inaudible]
HI RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE GATE [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
I WELL.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
BROWN [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
HI STONE.
WHITE HOUSE E..
FIVE EYES THIRTY SIX KNOW ZERO
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
SENATOR RUBIO UNDER PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR AT THE PRO TEM'S
DESK THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON PRESIDENTE
MEMBERS AT TODAY I STAND AS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF SENATE
RESOLUTION.
THIRTEEN DECLARING FEBRUARY
AMERICAN HEART MONTH AND
RECOGNIZING THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION CONRAD. FOR WOMEN
MOVEMENT IN CALIFORNIA I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LOS ANGELES FOR ASKING ME TO BE
A JOINT AUTHOR ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
EARLIER TODAY I WAS WALKING
AROUND WITH OUR GUESTS TODAY AT
THE AMERICAN ON I'M SORRY THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION ROOM
AND DASH WAS ASKED WHAT ARE THE
THREE THINGS ARE A FEW THINGS
THAT YOU WANT PEOPLE TO REMEMBER.
AND SHE HIGHLIGHTED A FEW THINGS
THAT I WANT TO REPEAT AND I
ALREADY KNOW THIS ALREADY SAD
BUT IS THAT IMPORTANT.
NUMBER ONE HEART DISEASE IS THE
NUMBER ONE KEY NUMBER 280% OF
HEART DISEASE AS PREVENTABLE
ALLOW SHE SAID 50% OF WOMEN DO
NOT REALIZE THAT HEART DISEASE
IS THEIR GREATEST HEALTH RISK.
AND NO ONE KNOWS BETTER THAN MY
FRIENDS WHO I WILL INTRODUCE
LATELY ROAD CHINA.
AT JUST THIRTY SEVEN YEARS OLD
LADY WILL TELL AS THE HEIGHT WAS
IN THE HEIGHT OF HER CAREER
WORKING MORE THAN SIXTY HOURS A
WEEK AS A SENIOR DIRECTOR FOR
GLOBAL.
EVENTS ASSOCIATION HER WORKLOAD
HAD TAKEN A HEAVY TOLL ON HER
BODY COST EXTREME STRESS.
AND CONSTANT WILL TRAVEL
SCHEDULE WAS EXHAUSTING.
SHE WOKE UP ONE MORNING WITH
SEVERE JOHN CHEST PAIN WITH HER
ENTIRE LEFT SIDE OF HER BODY NAM.
HOWEVER DESPITE LEAST DISCOMFORT
AS WE ALL DO SHE DECIDED TO
STILL GO INTO WORK.
WE'RE ALWAYS TAKING CARE OF
OTHERS BEFORE TAKING CARE OF
OURSELVES ONCE AT THE OFFICE
LADY MENTIONED HER UNUSUAL
SYMPTOMS TO HER BOSS WHO
INSISTED SHE WAS SUFFERING A
HEART ATTACK. ONE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO SURVIVED A HEART
ATTACK IMMEDIATELY VOLUNTEERED
TO TAKE HER TO THE HOSPITAL.
JUST A YEAR BEFORE LISA FOR THE
HEART ATTACK SHE FELT PERIODIC
TURNING ON HER LEFT CHEST AREA
BUT DID NOT UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS
COMING FROM OR THE POTENTIAL
DANGER SHE WAS ABOUT TO
EXPERIENCE.
LILY ATTRIBUTED THE TEST PAIN TO
THE STRESS OF HER DEMANDING JOB
AND LACK OF SLEEP HOWEVER A FEW
DAYS PRIOR TO HAVING A HEART
ATTACK HER FRIENDS AND FAMILIES
ALSO NOTED.
MEMORY LOSS.
NOW TEN YEARS AFTER THE
UNEXPECTED HEART ATTACK DALY HAS
MADE HER HEART AND BODY A
PRIORITY AS WE SHOULD ALL DO.
LAST YEAR LILY BECAME THE
OFFICIAL SPOKESPERSON FOR THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION AND
HAS PREVIOUSLY BEEN VOLUNTEERING
FOR THE ASSOCIATION FOR OVER
EIGHT YEARS.
I WAS EXTREMELY PROUD TO SEE MY
FRIEND IN WEEK REPRESENTING THE
ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE TO THANK
HER FOR TRAVELING TO SACRAMENTO
TODAY AS WELL AS THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION.
VOLUNTEERS WERE STANDING IN THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBERS AS WELL I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO
CELEBRATE THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION GO RED FOR WOMEN
MOVEMENT.
IN CALIFORNIA AND I WOULD LIKE
TO WELCOME AYE FRIENDLY RACHA
BALLING SO WARM WELCOME TO
SENATOR RUBIO WAS YES.
KILLER TOTALLY ROCHA.
THE FACE OF WOMEN AND HEART
DISEASE.
AND WHILE PHOTO IS BEING TAKEN
IT AT THE END OF SESSION
IMMEDIATELY THEREAFTER THERE
WILL BE A GROUP PHOTO. FOR ALL
WHO ARE WEARING RED IN HONOR OF
GO RED FOR WOMEN'S HEALTH DAY.
AT THE END OF MEDIA LEE UPON THE
END OF SESSION.
AND IF SOMEONE WOULD CLOSE THE
DOOR SOON AS THEY COULD WE CAN
GET THIS PHOTO TAKEN
[inaudible]
VERY GOOD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND I BELIEVE SENATOR SKINNER
YOU ALSO HAVE.
AN INTRODUCTION TO MAKE UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
COLLEAGUES IF YOU'LL GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION PLEASE. TO SENATOR
SKINNER.
WE HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST WITH US
THIS AFTERNOON [inaudible]
SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK LORD YOURS COLLEAGUES
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
SENATOR SKINNER.
COLLEAGUES IT IS MY GREAT HONOR
TO WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE FLOOR.
OUR FORMER CONGRESSWOMAN GABBY
GIFFORDS.
FROM TWO THOUSAND TO TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE CONGRESSWOMAN
GIFFORDS WAS THE YOUNGEST WOMAN
ELECTED TO ARIZONA STATE SENATE.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIX HE
BECAME THE THIRD WOMAN FROM
ARIZONA TO SERVE IN OUR U. S.
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
AND SERVED UNTIL.
TWENTY TWELVE UNFORTUNATELY THAT
SERVICE WAS CUT SHORT.
DUE TO GUN VIOLENCE ON JANUARY
EIGHTH.
TWENTY ELEVEN AT A CONGRESS ON
YOUR CORNER EVENT THAT SHE WAS
HOLDING IN TUCSON ARIZONA WITH
YOUR CONSTITUENTS HE WAS SHOT IN
THE HEAD FROM NEAR POINT BLANK
RANGE.
THERE WERE THIRTEEN OTHERS
WOUNDED AND SIX KILLED INCLUDING
A JUDGE AND ONE OF HER STAFF
MEMBERS AND A YOUNG CHILD.
TWENTY THIRTEEN ONE MONTH AFTER
THE MASS SHOOTING AT SANDY HOOK
ELEMENTARY CONGRESSWOMAN
GIFFORDS AND HER HUSBAND.
ANNOUNCED THE FORMATION OF AN
ORGANIZATION TO FIGHT GUN
VIOLENCE AND SINCE THEN THEY
HAVE HELPED TO WRITE PASS AND
ENACT LEGISLATION.
SHE AND HER HUSBAND NAVY VETERAN
AN ASTRONAUT CAPTAIN MARK KELLY
HAVE WORKED TIRELESSLY TO SAVE
LIVES FROM GUN VIOLENCE AND I'M
SURE MANY OF YOU HAVE SEEN
RESEARCH AND DATA.
FROM THE NONPROFIT THAT THEY
ESTABLISHED THE GIFFORDS
LAWCENTER O PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE SO I ASK THAT YOU
WELCOME CONGRESSWOMAN GIFFORDS
TO OUR FOR A WARM.
AND SINCE [inaudible]
ZERO THANK YOU.
THIS MOST COURAGEOUS.
A SPOKESPERSON FOR PEACE AND NON
VIOLENCE THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
HIS ARE HONORED TO HAVE YOU ON
OUR FLOOR
.
SO I THINK THAT TAKES
[inaudible]
COLLEAGUES.
WAIT ONE MORE MOMENT
.
COLLEAGUES WE ARE ALSO JOINED IN
THE CHAMBERS TODAY BY OUR FORMER
ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUES SOME FORMER
ASSEMBLY WOMAN PATTY LOPEZ
[inaudible]
WAY.
THIS IS IN THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
WELCOME YOU BACK
.
ALL RIGHT AT THIS POINT
COLLEAGUES WE MOVED TO THE DAILY
FILE.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
UNDER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES.
ARE THERE ANY MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS OR NOTICES SEEING
NONE.
WE WILL GO NOW TO THE FIRST ARE
THE INTRODUCTION AND FIRST
READING OF BILLS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 204-205-2062
007-208-2092.
TEN NOW TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE ITEM THREE
SENATOR CHIANG WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PROCEED WITH THIS ITEM.
ALL RIGHT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ COLLEAGUES WE ARE ON FILE
ITEM THREE SENATOR CHIANG
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RIGHT.
PLEASE GO AHEAD WITH THE READING
OF THE OF THE BILL.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI
RELATIVE TO KOREAN AMERICAN DAY.
SENATOR TRENT.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM PRESENCE FELLOW
COLLEAGUES IT IS MY HONOR TO
PRESENT ACR THREE TO YOU TODAY
WHICH WILL RECOGNIZE THIS PAST.
JANUARY THIRTEENTH TWENTY
NINETEEN AS KOREAN AMERICAN DAY.
THIS IS THE COME ROOM MEMORY
BILL ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTEENTH
ANNIVERSARY OF KOREAN
IMMIGRATION. TO AMERICA.
FROM NINETEEN NO THREE IN
NINETEEN OH SEVEN OVER A
THOUSAND KOREANS ARRIVED IN
HAWAII IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND NOW THERE ARE MORE THAN ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE OF
KOREAN DESCENT LIVING IN THE
UNITED STATES.
ORANGE COUNTY IS HOME TO THE
SECOND LARGEST CREAM POPULATION
IN THE UNITED STATES AND I AM
PROUD TO REPRESENT.
THE TWENTY NINE SENATE DISTRICT
ONE WITH SUCH A STRONG AND
VIBRANT KOREAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY.
KOREAN AMERICANS HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS MANY
FIELDS SUCH AS FINANCE
TECHNOLOGY MEDICINE AND MANY
MORE.
AND HAVE ALSO PROUDLY SERVE THIS.
I'M HONORED TO COMMAND KOREAN
AMERICANS WITH THE MY DISTRICT
AND ACROSS CALIFORNIA WITH ACR
THREE AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR CHANGE MADE
OUR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR TO
RUSSELL.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF ACR.
THREE MY VERY OWN SENATE
DISTRICT IS HOME TO FIFTY EIGHT
THOUSAND KOREAN AMERICANS.
ACCORDING TO THE US CENSUS
BUREAU LOS ANGELES HAS THE
LARGEST KOREAN AMERICAN
POPULATION IN THE COUNTRY.
IS ONE OF THE MOST DIVERSE
NEIGHBORHOODS ALSO IN MY
DISTRICT KOREATOWN INPUT
COMPASSES ROUGHLY THREE SQUARE
MILES -- AND
WAS AREA OF THE AREA WAS ONCE
THE EPICENTER OF THE GOLDEN AGE
OF HOLLYWOOD.
TODAY CAREER AND TOGETHER WITH
LIKE THE YOU KNOW POPULATIONS
CONTRIBUTE TO KOREA TOWNS RICH
CULTURAL DIVERSITY.
KOREATOWN IS ALSO KNOWN FOR
HAVING ONE OF THE LARGEST
CONCENTRATION OF BUSINESSES IN
THE COUNTRY I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER DORADO FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SING IN HEARING ON CENTER CHIANG
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ICE
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION PASSES.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM
FOR WHICH IS THE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
TEN ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
BOB MINUTE MATTER SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
BATES.
AYE BELL [inaudible] FIVE
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
I'D DRAWS THEM [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER.
AYE GROW [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADA.
I JACKSON.
AYE JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I GROW.
NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
I LIKE HUSKY.
AYE WIENER [inaudible]
I WILL [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
WORLD [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
STONE VICE THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
COLLEAGUES RETURNING NOW TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THIS IS
THE TIME TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY.
SENATOR BRADFORD WOULD YOU LIKE
TO START US OFF.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO JOURNEY
TO MEMBER IN MEMORY OF A
CONSTITUENT OF MINE A YOUNG MAN
BY THE NAME OF MARVIN.
THE ANDRE BROWN.
A INDIVIDUAL WHO I'M NOT KNOWN
PRETTY MUCH ALL OF HIS LIFE AND
ON DECEMBER TWENTY SEVENTH.
ARE THE LOSSES LIFE.
AT THE TENDER AGE OF THIRTY
EIGHT AND I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT WE ADJOURN ON
THIS DAY BECAUSE HE LOST HIS
LIFE TO A HEART ATTACK.
AGAIN AT THE YOUNG AGE OF THIRTY
EIGHT BUT I FIRST MET DE ANDRE
AT A AT THE SPRY ENERGETIC. NINE
YEAR OLD AND HE GRACE MAY.
BY PLANE ALL MY LITTLE LEAGUE
TEAM FOR FOUR YEARS HE WENT ON
TO BE NOT.
ONLY ONE OF THE MOST OUTSTANDING
ATHLETES I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
OF COACHING.
OVER SIXTEEN YEARS BUT A MUCH
BETTER INDIVIDUAL AND JUST ALL
AROUND GREAT KIA EVEN IF I WAS.
LATE FOR PRACTICE HE WOULD TAKE
IT UPON HIMSELF TO START
PRACTICE MAKING SURE EVERYBODY
DID PT AND ALL THE NECESSARY
DRILLS BEFORE WE TOOK TO FILL
OUT.
HE WAS SUCH A BASEBALL LOVER
THAT UPON --
AGING OUT OF LITTLE LEAGUE HE
WON ON THE PLAY A GUARDINO HIGH
SCHOOL WHERE I ATTENDED.
ANNUAL ALL STAR PLAYER THERE AND
AFTER GRADUATING FROM GUARDINO
HIGH SCHOOL AN INTERN EL CAMINO
HE TOO WANTED TO COACH ANY CAME
BACK TO HIS ALMA MATER MILE
AMONG THE MALL.
TO GUARDINO HIGH SCHOOL WHERE HE
COACHED FOR NUMEROUS YEARS.
HEY YOU PS.
HI HE WAS WELL LOVED AT U. P. S.
AND IT'S STILL SOMEWHAT IRONIC
THAT.
HE WORKED FOR UPS BECAUSE HE WAS
INDIVIDUAL WHO GAVE OF HIMSELF
ALL THE TIME HE WAS ALWAYS
ASKING WHAT HE COULD DO FOR
OTHER FOLKS AND IT'S APPROPRIATE
THAT.
HE WORKED ON WORK FOR UPS AND
WHAT WOULD CHAD A MODEL WHAT
COULD BROWN DO FOR YOU.
AGAIN DE ANDRE BROWN ALWAYS ASK
THAT QUESTION AS A YOUNG KID.
WILL BE SORELY MISSED BY HIS
FRIENDS HIS FAMILY HIS MOTHER
AND FATHER WHO WERE HEAVILY
INVOLVED AS YOUNG BROTHER
MARKETS WHO ALSO WAS A BAT BOY
FOR OUR TEAM WILL BE SORELY
MISSED BY.
THOSE THAT GUARDINO HIGH SCHOOL
I JUST ASKED THAT WE ADJOURNED
THIS SESSION AND IN MEMORY OF
THE I. JERRY.
BROWN.
THANK YOU SENATOR OF IF YOU
WOULD JOB BRING HIS NAME FORWARD
AGAIN SO WE CAN PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZE HIS MEMORY.
ARE.
GOING BACK TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI
MEN PRESENT IN COLLEAGUES THINK
YOU'RE JUST LIKE TO QUICKLY
ACKNOWLEDGE --
IN THE GALLERY TODAY MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY --
MANY OF US KNOW CCSD BECAUSE OF
THE FABULOUS --
SCIENCE FELLOWS THAT THEY HAVE
FIVE MY OFFICES ENJOYED HAVING
FIVE THAT SCIENCE FELLOWS HERE
SUIT THIS WEEK IS CCSD SCIENCE
AND TECHNOLOGY WEEK AT THE
CAPITOL ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY. TO
CHECK OUT THE AT THE EVENTS THAT
ARE ON THE CALENDAR SO THANK YOU
MAN PERSON.
THANK YOU CENTER RIGHT CASTING A
WARM WELCOME.
UNDER A A BIT AGAIN BACK TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORIES UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS --
SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.%
I RISE TO JOURNEY MEMORY OF JEFF
DIE --
VOLUNTEER WITH THE SEARCH AND
RESCUE --
FOR FILLMORE AND THE VENTURA
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT --
DIED THIS WEEKEND DURING THE
STORMS IN LA ON THE I FIVE
FREEWAY --
HE AND HIS CREW STOPPED ON THE
WAY UP TO A TRAINING --
KERR OF CANOGA PARK CONSTITUENTS
IT FLIPPED IN THEY PULLED OVER
THE SIDE OF FIVE OUT BY CASTAIC.
AND ANOTHER CAR RAN INTO THE THE
FIRE ENGINE AND KILLED JEFF AND
IS PUT TWO OF HIS PARTNERS IN
THE HOSPITAL THERE STILL IN
CRITICAL CONDITION --
AT HENRY MAYO --
LOOK.
PEOPLE LIKE JEFF HELP NOT EVEN
BECAUSE IT WOULD --
IT WAS A HIGH PAYING PROFESSION
OR BECAUSE IT WAS --
WAY TO GET ATTENTION BUT JUST
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THEY DO --
THEY ASSIST WHEN PEOPLE ARE IN
NEED ANY DIED DOING THAT AND
JUST A REMINDER HERE WE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF A LOT OF
SEEMS LIKE TOO MANY.
MEN AND WOMEN AMONG OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS THESE DAYS BUT WHEN
YOU'RE DRIVING YOUR CAR.
YOU'RE NOT JUST DRIVE IT.
IS THE CLOSEST ENCOUNTER WE HAVE
EVERY DAY TO DEATH AND IT'S A
STRANGE THING TO SAY I KNOW.
BUT THOSE OF US WHO SPECIAL
DRIVE ON LOS ANGELES LIKE
[inaudible]
PEOPLE THAT.
AND WHEN YOU'RE DRIVING UP THAT
FIVE NOT MINDING YOUR BUSINESS
AND YOU KNOW THE PEOPLE PEOPLE
LOSE THEIR LIVES SO --
MORNING FOR JAPANESE LEFT HIS
HIS WIFE SANDRA HIS MOTHER
BEHIND THEY THEY LIVED IN
FILLMORE EAST RAISED I MEAN THEY
LIVE IN THOUSAND OAKS REASON
FILLMORE.
WITH THAT ALL I'LL SEE TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE NORTH AND ASK
YOU EITHER TURN JUST MEMORY.
THANK YOU CENTERS TURN CENTER
JACKSON.
YES THANK YOU I TO WANT TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A JEFFREY
LEE DIE WHO WAS.
A MEMBER OF THE VENTURA COUNTY
SHERIFF'S FEEL MORE MOUNTAINS
SEARCH AND RESCUE VOLUNTEER
WHICH IS BASED IN.
IN THE NINETEENTH SENATE
DISTRICT WHICH I'M HONORED TO
REPRESENT --
THIS IS A RESCUE TEAM DALY
CERTIFIED VOLUNTEER.
VOLUNTEER BRANCH OF THE VENTURA
COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE.
THAT REQUIRES PARTICIPANTS LIKE
JEFF TO BALANCE THEIR DAYTIME
JOB HIS SAYS IN INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SECURITY MANAGER.
WITH COUNTLESS HOURS OF RIGOROUS
TRAINING IN SEARCH MANAGEMENT
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES AS
WELL AS URBAN AND WATER RESCUE.
AND THIS WAS A VOLUNTEER
POSITION HE WAS GOING OFF WITH
HIS COLLEAGUES TO A TRAINING
PROGRAM.
AND AGAIN AS A REMINDER I'D LIKE
TO REITERATE THE FACT THAT.
WHEN THE WEATHER IS BAD AND WHEN
THE RAIN IS COMING?
WE NEED TO BE MORE CAREFUL AS WE
DR OF THIS KIND OF ACCIDENT
HAPPENED WE SAW SOME DOUBTS ON
OUR ROADS IN IN MY DISTRICT AND
I'M SURE THROB CALIFORNIA WITH
THESE TERRIBLE RANGE.
IF YOU DRIVE TOO FAST.
YOUR CAR MAY HYDROPLANE.
AND WHEN THAT HAPPENS AS WE SAW
ALSO IN MY DISTRICT ARE THE THE
CAR CAN CROSS THE FREEWAY AND
HIT OTHER CARS HAD DOWN OR IN
THIS CASE.
HIT THE TRUCK THAT WEIGHED STOP
TO HELP A DISTRESSED MOTORIST
AND EIGHT OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS
TEAM WERE ALSO INJURED AS WAS
MENTIONED TO OTHERS ARE STILL IN
THE HOSPITAL IN CRITICAL
CONDITION.
A VEHICLE IS A DANGEROUS WEAPON.
NOT NECESSARILY INTENTIONALLY SO
BUT WE'VE LOST A LIFE OF ANOTHER
FINE VENTURA COUNTY SHERIFF'S.
DEPUTY VOLUNTEER AND WITH WOULD
ASK US ALL TO SEND CONDOLENCES
TO HIS WIFE AND TO HIS FAMILY.
WHO STILL LIVE IN FILLMORE AND
TO ALL OF US A?
A ANOTHER REMINDER OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF OUR PUBLIC
SERVANTS.
OF PEOPLE WHO GIVE THEIR TIME
THEIR ENERGY AND SADLY OFTEN
THEIR LIVES IN THE SERVICE OF
OTHERS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON THANK
YOU CENTER STERN PLEASE BRING
HIS NAME FORWARD SO WE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED.
MEMBERS THIS WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME TO CONTINUE
WITH THE JOURNEY MEMORIES IF
THERE ARE ANY.
IF THERE ARE NONE.
THEN --
THERE'S NO FURTHER BUSINESS
SENATOR WILK THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE.
AND WE WILL RECONVENE BACK HERE
ON THURSDAY FEBRUARY SEVENTH AT
NINE AM HAVE A GREAT WEEK.
THANK YOU THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
OTION WILL BE MADE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE AM
HAVE A GREAT REST TODAY MEMBERS.
HE SHOULD HAVE MANY